things are really not looking up for Fox
News propagandists Sean Hannity who of
course has both radio and television
programs and this actually goes back to
our vacation last week when Trump's
lawyer Michael Cohen revealed in court
or his lawyers did that Sean Hannity is
a client of Michael Cohen's
which immediately called into question
why Hannity didn't disclose that when
reporting critically about the way that
Cohen was being investigated by robert
muller hannity also immediately denied
that cohen was his lawyer which if you
believe the denial directly implies that
perjury took place that direct lies were
told in that courtroom when the claim
was made that cohen represented at some
point or currently sean hannity but the
broader picture is now becoming more and
more clear as we learn number one that
donald trump regularly talks to sean
hannity has had him at the white house
for dinner and it's not just a friendly
relationship because we're also learning
that sean hannity has a sort of mini
real-estate empire that's connected to
trump administration staffers including
cabinet secretary ben Carson and part of
Hannity's denial of Michael Cohen being
his attorney included Hannity saying
quote I've said many times on my radio
show I hate the stock market I prefer
real estate Michael Cohen knows real
estate so basically what Hannity is
saying here is Cohen wasn't my lawyer I
was talking to him informally about real
estate and the Guardian started looking
into Hannity's real estate holdings and
it turns out that he has a ton of real
estate that was not previously reported
and much of that real estate ownership
is through shell companies that spend
more than or have spent more than ninety
million dollars on nearly nine hundred
homes in seven states over the last ten
years and Hannity is the sort of hidden
owner of these properties many of those
properties purchased at a discount in
2013 after a huge string of foreclosures
stemming from the mortgage crisis that
was going on at time and the double
standard here of Hanna
slamming Obama for what was taking place
despite the fact that it wasn't actually
Obama's fault but personally taking
advantage of it and profiting from it is
just disgusting but that's not all there
is another concerning element here
Hannity was supported by the United
States Department of Housing and Urban
Development which he did not disclose
when he was praising Ben Carson
endlessly Trump's Secretary of Housing
and Urban Development is ben Carson he's
been on Sean Hannity's program before
and some of the properties that Hannity
bought including some in the state of
Georgia were bought with mortgages that
the Department of Housing and Urban
Development helped Sean Hannity obtain
through something called the National
Housing Act and the loans were upped by
five million dollars with support from
none other than Ben Carson's HUD
Department Hannity has interviewed Ben
Carson and never disclosed his financial
interest when talking to Carson about
HUD and housing policy he just praised
privatization that Donald Trump and
Carson wanted to do it is all incredibly
sketchy Hannity reports on Michael Cohen
without mentioning that Cohen is his
attorney or was or is his real estate
advisor Hannity interviews ben Carson
and praises the policy without
mentioning that he's working with HUD to
obtain gigantic loans to buy properties
that he then I guess presumably rent out
Hannity also works with the wealth
management firm whose principal is Bill
Aiko who Hannity has interviewed on his
program without disclosing that
relationship and that same bill Leigh
co-wrote op-eds
slamming the robert muller investigation
and no disclosure whatsoever total
propagandist and total lack of
disclosure and once again the guys
screaming about corruption by obama
corruption by robert muller he's
actually the guy covering up the massive
conflicts of interest here yeah and I
remember after Trump became president
people started calling Fox News
state-run media yeah because they were
just Peres whatever the administration's
position is and then later on we were
like actually maybe it's media run state
because Trump will get up at 5:00 in the
morning and watch Fox and Friends and
tweet whatever the anchors say and run
his policy based on what the anchors on
Fox have to say sure now it's like I
don't know which one it is state-run
media media run state it so when you're
twined at this point basically just a
melting pot of the two together and I
don't think anybody in our audience is
going to be surprised that Hannity's
radio and TV programs not only are they
trading in total propaganda it's
actually calculated profiteering for
Sean Hannity personally from the
propaganda that he puts out not at all
surprising to me and at least he's a
super nice guy right and I still stand
by that when I met Sean Hannity he was
way nicer to me then most of the
progressive media people Tom Hartman was
the best nicest guy
same thing with John Cougar but a lot of
the progressive media people were really
not nice when I met them and Hannity was
a super nice guy did Hannity know your
politics though uh yeah you were
conservative didn't matter
didn't matter just was not was not even
an issue I wonder if he's sort of
playing a character kind of like he's
lent savvy Alex Jones of playing if he's
playing a character it's one that's very
personally profitable for him so it's an
incredibly valuable business character
for him that's for damn sure